you want me to go on a date ooh just to
be clear i am just talking about a
two-dip into the dating pool one guy
okay
and just like that carrie bradshaw is
back on the dating scene oh god i think
we're gonna need some drinks yep during
the latest episode of hbo max's sex in
the city revival series everyone's
favorite relationship columnist has
penned a new book detailing the
devastating heartbreak of her husband
big dying a plot twist that left fans of
the show reeling too i love that people
are upset it means they care they felt
loss which is what's a it's fiction so
it's fun to feel
sad if it's not real
it's fun to to feel
pain if it's not on if it's fortunately
not your pain fictional pain is
what art's for it helps us get through
real life sometimes but back to carrie
the writer meets with her editor to get
feedback on the book and it's mostly
good news well except for this
i would love and i think this is very
doable
if you could give the reader some
element of hope i mean for example
i imagine at some point you're gonna
start dating again right
um
i mean i'm not even thinking about that
yet i hear you
but if there's a tiny part of you that's
open to the idea of even just one date
it would be great if it could happen in
the next few weeks
yeah carrie's editor urges her to go on
a date so the book isn't too depressing
and after a little convincing and a
mention that oprah winfrey has expressed
interest in featuring it in her famous
book club carrie agrees
so
i guess i'm going on a date and thanks
to kyrie's new friend and realtor seema
she's all set up and ready to go with an
online dating profile and decides to try
out a date with peter a 53 year old
teacher and widower i have to admit um
this is my first date since my wife died
yeah me too
okay
how did your husband die if you don't
mind me asking
no um
he had a heart attack
and your wife cancer uh ovarian
oh god
i think we're gonna need some drinks
yeah well they have those drinks one too
many in fact this is your warning
projectile vomiting in three
two
one
[Laughter]
so needless to say the date didn't go so
great but props to carrie for ripping
off the band-aid when it spoke to sarah
jessica parker at the show's premiere
she opened up about revisiting her
character over a decade after filming
the movie sex in the city too
we felt excited about
the kind of stories that we were
interested in telling and we were
curious as to you know about where they
were and who they were and what was
their life like and who were they now
surrounded by well update according to
carrie her dating life is officially
hopeless
apologies to my readers there is no
light at the end of the tunnel just
vomit
but things get interesting when it turns
out peter is actually a teacher at
charlotte's kid's school and actually
attends the same fundraiser as carrie
who offered a date with her as an
auction item that
literally no one wanted to bid on
date with sex writer carrie bradshaw
five hundred dollars
can't we're all married ah you know what
i bit a thousand
i bit a thousand and now you can uh
okay a thousand dollars
going once going twice
a thousand fifty
one thousand fifty dollars
once twice sold
thousand fifty yep peter won the auction
and following the event he assured
carrie they didn't actually have to go
out again don't worry
we don't actually have to go out again
yeah
and i'm happy to cover your bid you know
that was clearly charity for
all parties no no no no i wouldn't think
of it but in a sweet twist gary has a
change of heart
yeah okay let's do it
it's for the kids
look at the kids yes
and just like that carrie has a second
date but will the revival series get a
second season e.t recently chatted with
sarita chaudhry who plays sema and while
she didn't have an official answer she
said she's hoping for it
you know when you bring in new
characters and you just start
establishing and everyone's now getting
used to everyone all of us have grown up
you know carrie's grown up i feel like
the second would be able to just
jump into
who they really are as opposed to
getting the audience used to
seeing what they're seeing
and so i would love the second season